welcome to this view about round seven
of the Chess Olympiad I'm catching up
here with my coverage and Sam rod was
played on September fourth so as the
video is uploaded yon filters from
yesterday and the seventh round had a
couple of really high-profile clashes he
on top Russia beat Azerbaijan with three
drawers and Grisha winning over Safari
pretty nice rity gical game also I'm
good to look at if you're interested I'm
a medium actually am yeah a bit
surprisingly lost to China with the most
easy on being defeated by wrong you and
three drawers Hungary played a
surprising 22 against the Philippines
who really young put up a strong
performance IAM ukraine bebita spain
with was it even shocked scoring an
important win on bought one and three
drawers and yeah for for the german on
spectators here germany beat moldova in
a very important match to keep contact
with the metal places some two and a
half one and a half with wins by a moose
of solid ego Jenkin and the law firm by
guilt maíam but as mentioned compensated
by the two wins so germany is still in
contention for some top ranks um yeah
i'm going to present of course one game
of this round and it's not of the
absolute top boards they have been some
interesting games but I simply must show
this game it's um it's a nicer a nice
fight between grand master nor off
resume from france and grandmaster
Emile's of top ski for me so if you
watch my channel constantly you might
remember an amazing game that i've
featured recently between
tabu player animals each oak and so
toski playing black which was one of the
most amazing technical battles that have
seen recently and so tarski is really
really a player to watch out for
spectacular chassis simply not able to
play a boring game unless it's really
yes sometimes happening by accident but
usually you're into fireworks watch the
toski yeah he is playing black against
Francis Oh top player for his name and
let's see what happens he opens with
them one night of three and um so
Trotsky is the groom felt expert so he
tries to go for the goon felt but
presently chooses entire room felt so we
only have this this kind of version
which is similar in a strategical
content but still somewhat different is
white hasn't played t4 here white has
really a ton of moves at its disposal
pretty plates queen bee three which is
interesting um one simple point is okay
this night is attacked obviously it
needs to move you can also protect it
but this looks rather passive a move
like c6 and black am not really play the
usual capture because Queen see three
years a very embarrassing move as the
rook is now attacked in the corner and
black needs to play the yeah this is a
very ugly move or look g8 which she also
probably don't want to play at least it
looks very young very weird so like um
taking it's not really the way to go he
went back with them Knight b6 yeah now
white occupies the center deform Bishop
g7 and dumb ephone so it is it is really
a good fall to type of position after
all yeah black now play Bishop g4
immediately increasing the pressure on
on the d4 point
taking the night you hear why to choose
an interesting move which has become
fashionable lately let's check on me
five which yeah provokes black into some
reaction um yeah I cannot play the
desired move 96 as now white can play d5
and it's maybe not completely clear in
terms of losing a piece but it should be
should be fine for white so um he more
or less needs to go for this move after
which white has an interesting
possibility and also the move that reads
a neighbor lady played Knight to g5
immediately attacking f7 and ignoring
the fact that this Bishop is attacked so
black gown castled first here and now
wide retreated the bishop and in this a
funny way um yeah initiates a trade of
these two pieces but the bishop wasn't
able to trade itself for the night so
that the default point is strengthened
strengthened and away after this the two
nite protects the porn they provide
returns with the g5 night then centers
yeah nicely protected but this whole
maneuver has has another point actually
and with these healers in the game so
toski now develops a piece of 9 a-6 and
this is some yea rather than interesting
a way to develop the night but it's a
good one I prepare c5 and also night
before as possible at some point
obviously not at the moment as the queen
is covering this but we see white place
this long Queen move all the way to h3
end simply threatens checkmate after
this night before is indeed a source of
counter play for black so the night is
more active here then let's say on g7
alright but white simply thread is
checkmate and what should like do not
much choice he moved to some this pawn
I'm a move like h5 you always have to
consider maybe not right away but even
consider a move like g-form it might get
very interesting oops no this one simply
threatened like and try this kind of
stuff after which White has multiple
ideas you can you can take just not bad
but you can also try to play something
like this year and continuing to attack
the king very unclear possibilities but
what sadowski played h6 looks that looks
much more logical to me so aged 6 wide
retreated and now queen t 7 checking in
a way the screen so that why does it
have the time to capture on h6 if you
were to take now like an first exchange
and then win the peace so this way I'm
he covered h6 yet white of course
doesn't want to exchange Queens it
doesn't make so much sense after you
move the Queen's oven so quit him and
still attacking age 6 yeah now black
doesn't have real choice he went for
each five now but in the meantime he has
over protected the g four square so that
white cannot go g4 immediately and yeah
here in this position wyd infect them
has some a choice to make a very
important one either to really burn burn
all your bridges and go from all-out
attack or play em yeah in a normal sort
of fashion white could could just play a
normal movie em let's say castles or
maybe a bit more aggressive Bishop g5
for taking the porn and I think white is
perfectly all right here let's say rook
e8 castles and I guess this position
should be around equal
the 10 to the center of wides is some
nice looking but it cannot really am
yeah advanced at the moment I think this
position should be rocked roughly equal
like he has also the chance to get to
get the Queens of the board which
usually helps them so this would have
been the the normal kind of continuation
but he'll player from France they really
went for it he went 83 in this position
preventing a queen g4 and also simply
been threatening or intending to play g4
and break up the King position so really
info fight and okay he found exactly the
right opponent to make real firework out
of this game so black plate to c5
immediately I'm seeking for counter play
in the center and this is certainly
right g-form has planned there's no
really am no going back really once you
played h3 you really need to go for it
so G for like took he um could have also
played night before would have been
interesting also immediately threatening
this move they don't want to make this
an hour long video it's easily possible
here in this game okay he decided after
g42 to take on default which is also
quite sensible you also have this deep
or now as an attacking unit yeah so why
took age five and yeah here black
had a choice he played a d3 which I
think might be inaccurate but obviously
this is so complicated position that um
it's it's really hard to tell so this
was played probably 95 was the better
move to get this night into the game
more quickly it is some still very
complicated one point of this night move
is that actually taking now is bad for
white because after this there are media
threats on f3 and ninety-three so if
white now would play as it was intended
to do now g5 with the main thread and
then you can actually get a tech first
and it gets really ugly something like
this year check and it turns out that
why check only has one check and after
this is pretty much over and now all
kinds of material is hanging and black
is the one with the huge attack the
problem also is where should white go I
mean if he goes here I can socially can
simply take this and white still doesn't
have any any good good place to go so
this night c5 move would have prevented
the taken the taking on g6 and the game
we played III first and now why do I
took and plate 95 and of course now
there is no direct counter play with a
93 maneuver and yeah okay white thread
the simple check made some black needs
to move this rook to make some yeah some
room for the king
bleh Brooke f6 which is I think the only
move which he or she could play now
white went night F for getting this
piece into the tech as well and yeah now
it gets really dangerous her black he
played king queen to d6 which is
probably the best move the problem here
is if black plays um yeah and the move
like not before let's let's just put one
on the board with this idea then white
execute this idea and I takes 26 and
this is just winning immediately
threatening the check made black hand
can also give a check it really doesn't
matter it's still the same kind of idea
like now takes which she needs to do
then we have this position and this is
this is actually resigned about f7 is
simply not them yeah not easy to cover
what should you do I mean this one check
it's answered by brother check check
winning the queen or if he goes here
usually just win all kinds of material
so this is the problem in this position
like really only has some the move in
the game queen to d6 and here I think is
the key position of this whole game well
white could have played much better than
what he did but this is really am yeah
super difficult to do as the the move
that is best here according to computer
analysis it's not really a movie would I
think consider so um yes family he
should have played actually just castles
despite all this castles is the best
move with the idea to quickly user use
your rook again this is D pawn
and as far as I see and then that
resistance is basically winning for
white but it leads to variations which
are for human over the board really
super tough to to assess one possibility
is so for instance Nigel see for him to
which 95 is quite strong why just
continues to attack and even if black
gun wins material in this fashion it
still is a huge attack for white here
here why can just bring more pieces into
the tech and black really am doesn't
have any good defensive opportunities
for example something like this gets
very ugly turn down I did I just did the
red line yeah I did she sorry something
like this and what should like do now f7
as it's just let's just check made you
can play something like this the only
move that yeah prevents me a checkmate
but then White has all kinds of stuff
even this kind of moves as possible the
idea being to go here or possibly to
have form and yeah as you can see check
this won't the Queen and you've got a
deadly maging attack on top so castling
really what's the right move but it's
it's it's insanely difficult to to
calculate and also if you look at freds
and a smooth Luke g1 it looks completely
logical putting this Rogan to use and
it's em it's super super tough to play
this position yeah black played 94 and
by the way why does not not severely
were CM most probably he still has got
an interesting attack going 95
and here sadowski played the strong move
night before getting now both nights
into attacking positions and really
getting huge counterplay also with the
deep on yeah here Y term had an
alternative he took on f6 so it also
would have been interesting maybe better
to play this move gaining a tempo on the
Queen and this some leads to some really
crazy lines for example you 593 xf6
check greene takes strike on h7 King f8
and now watching even sacrifice a more
material to to break through and
something like this for example leads to
leads to a very very complicated
position it's probably good for for
black but it's not not completely
completely easy I'm sorry I'm I simply
as if we butchered the line him takes
and now first black needs the playoffs
yeah route cakes like needs to play this
first of course because there was the
thread and this in fact seems to be good
for black but all these lines are really
super complicated so Bishop f4 here in
this position was a serious alternative
what he played was okay though he took
some took on f6 and this is of course I
would say I i did some analysis of this
game obviously but it's very complicated
I can could easily overlooked something
or didn't give the computer enough time
to calculate it probably I think this
move was still ok Queen f6
but now in this really complicated
position wyd I think made the decisive
mistake but it wasn't and all easy to
figure it out um probably needs to play
a move like king of one here and trying
to play something like this getting the
King into relative safety and just
giving up a piece for this pawn this
pawn will win a material anyway this was
probably still playable what you did is
rook g3 and this is I think losing but
very difficult to to work out yeah so
top ski player to check on D to the
bishop takes check and night see to
check and here King you want is the most
obvious continuation and also the move
that Fred in a plate um alternatives
also fail to impress if he goes let's
say [ __ ] here get this problem check
and like well yeah win with the
checkmate even in a couple of moves so
this was basically the only idea and now
the cool move roughly eight going for
counter play on d2 already a really
spectacular position right now played
'if I've trying to ya get the Queen out
of the F file so that Queen h7r okay
three is a stronger attack yeah black
first check took this check King see one
yeah and what did like play now the
Queen's hanging there's Queen f7 check
in the air look at three in the air all
kinds of stuff and what did black play
you didn't move the Queen it just played
the various setting move at 94 and the
point being if white would now capture
the Queen check its check
need very beautiful check media
accomplished with two nights and the
rook very very easy on the eye this
checkmate very nice so white cannot take
the Queen so what should he do the
problem is simply this mentioned mating
idea and wider really has only one move
to prevent a direct disaster direct made
is to to take it a night and first you
might think okay others into bed if
black now would take on you for you just
take here and this position isn't clear
at all why does it exchanged up or black
as some compensation but it's totally
irrelevant this line simply because
afterward Queen takes d4 so Toph ski
played the amazing move just kept just
go into c6 and he threatens checkmate
Queen h1 with checkmate to follow and
this is simply a square that it's not
possible for y 2 y a2 to cover the only
idea to do this is this maybe move like
this but after this move like and simply
take here and the rookies attacked this
is the threat on v2 with all kinds of
nice lines let's say it takes here check
yeah at first cause do you even think
you might be checkmate but there's the
rook covering it so this is not working
but can simply take here and this will
get lost yeah black is probably winning
in this position evening also because
it's not just the taking that is
threatened but also Ruby one
yeah a couple of really cool lines here
after the really cold blood its fifth
winter going to see six also note that
white cannot even give a check on the
end because the rookies is protecting
this so um yeah there's simply no move
and so the queen is also hanging and you
can block this yeah and then simply take
the Queen so wide at the end needed to
take there was not not much else he
needs to sacrifice the Queen to get out
of the media disaster kingly too we
should we find that and after all this
complications we actually got a position
with equal material but that the only
thing that is really equal in this
position the main problem is that yet
the bishop is very strong only five
hurting pressure with the whole board
and whites king is wide wide open and
this is the main point Bishop mend and
Queenie a will attack this King and also
win a couple of pawns in the process
white really is lost here he played rook
here check like it could give the check
in the center and now captured v2 and a
tooth or so this is two pawns up and
wide really couldn't prevent this the
pawns and the old structure was simply
to open end to lose and yeah white
continues her bitching and at the end
like wonders fairly easily now by
pushing the a porn in fact after a five
Frison they already resigned which team
seemed a bit early maybe he also over
overstepped the time this is possible
after this this game look at this game
it would be a very much understandable
that the clock here um says- something-
350 so maybe he really a lost some time
but ok the position is also winning
with the a pawn supported by the bishop
ourselves somebody too strong yeah I
think a very attractive game with this
amazing move first Knight to g4 and with
the point Queen takes on d4 and the blow
Queen to see six now in tending the
check made and now attacking the queen
with a winning position form for black
yeah very nicely played game here by a
certain ski who are as usual headed very
yeah and he had some difficult moments
in the game if you play so sharply yet
it can happen but it was simply too
difficult to to play correctly and at
the end of blacks initiative really here
11 the point with the same temporary
Queen sec yeah so toski is really a
player you should look into if you enter
while tactics and and interesting
attacks is maybe the the sharpest player
there is is he's even a bit more some
capacity these at times a bit more than
into the complicated stuff and then
shear off yeah okay so thanks for
watching help you enjoyed this game
selection of her round seven they have
been some other cool games but I like
this one it was really spectacular with
94 Queen c6 other as the technical
points of blacks plane yeah thanks for
watching